so effectively including Javelin
anti-tank missiles artillery ammunition
and conventional and long-range rockets
for U.S provided highmars additional
information on the Security package can
be found on defense.gov
in regards to our announcement last
night regarding the High Altitude
surveillance balloon I'm not going to
have much new information to provide
other than to say that the North
American Aerospace Defense command
continues to monitor it closely while we
won't get into specifics in regards to
the exact location I can tell you that
the balloon continues to move Eastward
and is currently over the center of the
continental United States again we
currently assess that the balloon does
not present a military or physical
threat to people on the ground at this
time and will continue to review excuse
me continue to Monitor and review
options finally secretary Austin will
host a bilateral meeting today here in
the Pentagon with Australian Deputy
Prime Minister and Minister of Defense
Richard Morris the secretary looks
forward to discussing bilateral defense
cooperation and Our Mutual Security
efforts within the indo-pacific region
and Beyond a full readout of the
engagement will post later today to
defense.gov and with that we'll go ahead
and move to your questions we'll start
with ap Tarka
hi Pat thank you for doing this
um China has said this is just a weather
balloon that has veered off course why
is the Pentagon convinced that this is a
surveillance balloon and then can you
give us a little bit more on the status
of the balloon you said it's in the
central of the central U.S what state do
you have any guidance for people as they
see this balloon or they're trying to
photograph it or maybe try and interfere
with it sure uh thanks Tara uh so first
of all we are aware of the prc's
statement However the fact is we know
that it's a surveillance balloon and I'm
not going to be able to be more specific
than that we do know that the balloon
has violated U.S airspace and
international law which is unacceptable
and so we've conveyed this directly to
the PRC at multiple levels and in terms
of specific locations I'm not going to
be able to go into specific locations
again other than to say it's moving
Eastward at this time
yeah you had a follow-up
we'll just start to see the balloon do
you have any guidance for should they
try not to interfere not photograph
so the balloon is currently assessed to
be at about 60 000 feet so again well
above uh the the range of civilian air
traffic or work civilian air traffic
would normally fly
um certainly aware that there are
cameras uh you know civilian owned
commercial cameras that could spot this
balloon in in terms of guidance to folks
again this is something that Norad is
closely monitoring we do assess at this
time that it's not pose a physical
threat as I mentioned to people on the
ground so we'll just leave it at that
Jennifer
General writer who is controlling this
balloon right now
uh again we know that this is a Chinese
balloon but beyond that I'm not going to
have specifics but is it you say that
it's moving Eastward and it's over the
continental U.S it's it's not over
Montana anymore is the Chinese
government controlling the movement of
the balloon or is it just floating with
uh airstreams thanks Jennifer uh so I'm
not going to go into any specific
intelligence that we may have again uh
we we know this is a Chinese balloon and
that it has the ability to maneuver but
I'll just leave it at that and once it's
over a body of water will you shoot it
down again right now we're monitoring
the situation closely uh reviewing
options but beyond that I'm not going to
have any additional information let me
go to Tony
one quickie on the uh on the on the
balloon can you confirm the photos that
are out there that this is not the man
in the moon and that is the actual
balloon uh thanks Tony so uh certainly
aware of photos being posted online uh
I'm not gonna get into the business of
confirming uh whether or not those are
you know where those photos come from
again I can tell you that the US
government NORAD is monitoring this
closely uh and we will continue to
review up how close was the U.S to
ordering a was the president ordering a
shoot down of the balloon
yeah so again I'm not going to get into
discussions internal discussions within
the White House again uh right now we
assess that there is no threat a
physical threat or military threat to
people on the ground so we're continuing
to monitor
um you know and we'll just leave it at
that thank you let me go to Janie and
then we'll go to Rio
thanks General welcome to home
I have a two occasions please come on
okay in response to secretary Austin's
recent remarks that the more U.S
strategic assets will come to the South
Korea nurse could be a Wonder of a
stronger provocations in the near future
what is your comment on this
um well it's certainly not surprising
given North Korea's track record of
making bellicose statements again what
we're focused on is on preserving peace
security and stability in the
indo-pacific region and so secretary
Austin's visit was an opportunity to
again reaffirm our strong and close
alliance with the Republic of Korea and
so that will remain our focus is on
working with South Korea and other
nations in the region to deter
aggression and ensure a free and open
indo-pacific
South Korea has announced that it will
be a test high powered monster ballistic
missile with the nuclear warhead level
it is this is a defense against North
Korea's nuclear warhead
how do you agree this
I'm sorry Gina I missed the first part
of your questions South Korea has
announced that it will be a test a high
powered monster ballistic missile with
the world nuclear warhead levels this is
yeah I don't have anything on that I'd
refer you to the government of South
Korea thank you let me go to Rio and
then I'll come back over here okay thank
you very much uh two questions on the
Chinese balloon so there is a
speculation that is over Japanese
airspace before reaching the U.S
continental U.S can you confirm that
I've seen those press reports again as
we acknowledged in our statement uh that
we posted last night we have seen uh
this type of balloon activity elsewhere
before but again I'm not going to get
into intelligence and I'm not going to
have any further information to provide
secondary how will this incident affect
the secretary's future engagement with
Chinese counterparts to maintain the
open lines of the communication I think
we've been very clear that we're always
open to maintaining an open line of
communication uh with the PRC uh and in
that regard nothing has changed thank
you let me go to Phil and then I'll come
over to custom
position of the balloon classified
Phil right now what we're not going to
do is get into a hour-by-hour location
of the balloon again we're monitoring it
closely as I mentioned right now it's
over the center of the continental
United States that's about as specific
as I'm going to get I understand might
be inconvenient but as the public not
have a right to know the public
certainly has the ability to look up in
the sky and and see where the balloon is
thank you caution General you said
balloon is maneuverable uh so does that
mean that it's not drifting
uh so the balloon is maneuverable
um clearly it's in it's violated U.S
airspace uh and again we've communicated
that fact to the PRC if possible can you
tell us if the balloon when it enters
entered the U.S airspace has it changed
its course in any way
the balloon has changed its course uh
which is again why we're monitoring it
but that's about as specific as I can
get thank you go to Matt
so you said at this point
um the balloon doesn't pose to have any
to pose any risks to Citizens how is it
that the U.S can assess that given that
the balloon is at such an altitude you
know without actually getting eyes on it
up close and assessing the equipment
that's on board
um and secondly are there any
alternatives being considered to
shooting it down is there any option to
take this balloon out of the sky intact
to maybe get a better look at that
equipment yeah so so again uh this is a
surveillance balloon uh hover you know
operating at about 60 000 feet
um
clearly you know we did a very close
assessment in terms of uh what it's
doing and as I mentioned uh military
commanders have assessed that there is
no physical or military threat to people
on the ground
um and so in that regard we'll continue
to monitor uh in terms of way ahead we
will continue to review options but I'm
not going to have anything further to
provide on that so thank you ma'am
thank you Pat you said that this is a
violating our airspace so why not take
it down
yeah so uh you know clearly as we assess
options
um and considering the the size of the
payload on this uh looking at the
potential for debris uh and the impact
on civilians on the ground or property
damage again uh running through the the
various factors and looking at uh in
terms of does it pose a potential risk
to people while in the air and right now
as I mentioned we we assess that it does
not pose a risk to people on the ground
as it currently is traversing the
continental United States and so out of
an abundance of caution uh cognizant of
the potential impact to civilians on the
ground from a debris field right now
we're going to continue to Monitor and
review options and if I may you
mentioned that we've seen this kind of
activity before so why are we sharing
this one and why last night if you were
following it for a few days is this some
sort of sign that we should take from
China ahead of Lincoln's visit or or
from the activity that we had in the
Philippines yeah so in terms of any uh
you know hypotheticals about messaging
from PRC I'd refer you to them on that
front again I think what makes this
different different is uh the duration
and the length of which it has been over
uh U.S territory but beyond that I'm not
going to be able to go into any more
specifics Mike
uh thanks Pat
um yesterday a senior defense official
said that the intelligence gathering
capability of this balloon would be no
better than any uh Chinese satellite in
a low earth orbit if that's the case why
would Beijing go through the trouble and
expense to send this balloon on such a a
journey yeah I'd have to refer you back
to the PRC any opinion why again look
we're monitoring this as I mentioned
it's violated U.S airspace it's violated
international law we've communicated
that back to the government of China but
again I'd refer you back to China in
terms of of
but I assume that you're that the
Pentagon is trying to figure this out
itself why why they're bothering to do
this if they can already if it's
offering no better intelligence
gathering than from a uh a satellite
right yeah again I mean that that's a
statement not a question so uh yeah the
question mark at the end of it yeah
again I'm not going to have anything
other to provide so ma'am
yeah
go to her and then come back to Nancy
here
um I was wondering is there any way that
the Pentagon is able to gauge how long
it could potentially loiter
um you know comparing to balloons that
have been in the past
um and you know how long do you
anticipate that it could lawyer sure
yeah so so as I mentioned we'll continue
to monitor it uh right now we assess
that it'll probably be over the United
States for a few few days
um but we'll continue to monitor review
our options and keep you updated as as
we can thank you okay let me go to Nancy
here
hi General I want to go back to a couple
of things you said you said several
times that the US was reviewing its
options
I'd like to some clarity is the option
of shooting down the balloon
particularly as it's going over more
populated areas off the table is that
still amongst the options that that the
US military is considering and if so
under what conditions would it do so
yeah thanks Nancy so so at this stage uh
what I can tell you is again
um we're reviewing options I'm not I'm
not going to go into more specifics than
that uh and when and if there's any
updates to provide we'll let you know
it's been ruled out again we're
monitoring it we're reviewing options no
just leave it there and then a senior
defense official yesterday said that
um similar incidents had happened under
the previous administration and yet some
of those Administration officials have
come forward and said they're not
familiar with it is there any way you
can give us more details on when it's
happened over whether it was over the
Continental of the uh us or over U.S
territories is that something you would
potentially take to provide the public
more details about the extent that these
things happen so what I would tell you
right now is that information is
classified provide I'm not able to
provide it other than I can confirm that
there have been other incidents where
balloons did come close to or cross over
U.S territory and then I just want to
reiterate something that Phil said
earlier that given that it's not
classified and the public can see it I
just ask that you take the question that
we have more specifics on where it is
given that there's no clear security
Reason by your own estimation in terms
of keeping that information from them
sure absolutely and again
um you know we're just not going to get
into an hour by hour where the balloon
is so we will do our best to keep you
and the public informed in general terms
on where the balloon is uh and you know
try to be helpful in that regard
ing game where people think it's flying
over I just think some Fidelity would be
in everybody understood and again I
think a key Point here to make uh and
and to purposefully belabor the point
which is that again as this balloon
traverses the continental United States
we assess that it currently does not
pose a physical or military risk to
people on the ground so we will continue
to monitor we'll continue to review our
options and provide information and
updates as we're able to so Jennifer
is Washington DC
Again Jennifer we're reviewing options
but I'm not going to get into
hypotheticals or speculate on potential
future actions so let me go to the back
of the room here and then I'll come up
to do
thank you Junior
um thinking about the root of the
balloon uh was it impossible for the dod
to deal with the balloon before it reach
you to the you know airspace of the
United States yeah so uh we've been
monitoring the balloon
um
you know we we are aware
um again as I mentioned it as a
maneuverable craft
um and and we continue to assess and
make appropriate decisions uh based on
on how we're going to address you know
what we perceive as a Potential Threat
or not the Safety and Security of the
American people is Paramount uh and so
again at this time we assess that it
does not pose a physical threat to
people on the ground uh we'll continue
to monitor it and we'll continue to
review options thank you let me go ahead
and go to Joe here and then we'll come
back to this side of the room
so you said that this is the first time
we've uh this isn't the first time we've
seen a balloon fly over the continental
U.S in the past has it flown over other
sensitive areas such as military bases
you've only you haven't been very
specific it's just the continental U.S
yeah no I appreciate it I haven't been
very specific because that information
is classified I'm just not going to be
able to talk about it so thank you
Idris
the Canadian defense Ministry yesterday
said they were tracking a second
potential uh spy balloon are you
tracking a second potential incident and
when the balloon was coming I I guess
what I'm confused about is when were
their discussions to shoot down the
balloon were there any discussions about
shooting down the balloon when it was
not over the United States when it was
potentially over international waters or
with the discussions only when it
entered U.S airspace yeah thanks
teachers so on your first question
um we we are tracking one balloon uh so
in regards to statements by Canada I'd
refer you back to them on that
um in terms of uh the discussions about
whether or not to shoot down this
balloon
um that was uh an option right and so
that was something that was taken into
consideration again because we assessed
that currently it does not pose a
physical or military risk to people on
the ground for now we're continuing to
Monitor and review options
thank you I'll go back to Ellie and then
we'll come up here
thank you um how big is the balloon that
you're tracking and is it have you guys
picked up is it leaving anything in its
wake like sensors
yeah so so on your latter uh question
I'm not going to get into intelligence
um we do continue to monitor the balloon
we do know that it is a surveillance
balloon in terms of the size I'm not
able to get into the specifics other
than to say uh that it is big enough uh
that again in reviewing uh our approach
we do recognize that any potential
debris field would be significant and
potentially cause civilian uh injuries
or deaths or significant property damage
so again this is part of the calculus in
terms of our overall assessment but
again we'll continue to monitor it we'll
continue to review our options and keep
you updated as able let me go here and
then over here
uh thank you following up on the balloon
question uh during your conversation
with the Chinese
have they indicated to you what is
inside the balloon to prove the point
that it's not it's a civilian balloon of
weather monitoring thing and does that
assessment differs from your assessment
of what is inside the balloon what is
trying to do and secondly on the on
India question this week India and U.S
launched a uh initiative on critical
emerging Technologies uh this has a
quite a bit of Defense component in it
can you give us some more details about
it and how is it going to strengthen uh
build up your relationship with India
sure on your second question I'll have
to take that because I just don't have
that information in front of me on the
first question I appreciate it as I
mentioned we have contacted the PRC I'm
not going to get into uh their reaction
I'd I'd refer you uh to them for that
but we have clearly communicated uh that
this balloon is violating U.S airspace
and international law and that this is
unacceptable thank you go over here and
then go over here
thank you sir is the uh Pentagon looking
at any uh
possibility of maybe altering the course
of the balloon to take us to a location
where they can shoot it down in a rural
area
again monitoring we're reviewing options
but I'm not going to go into any further
specifics thank you sir
considering that this is a surveillance
balloon as you said uh does it have
ability to collect very sensitive data
given that it flies over nuclear sites
in the state of Montana
yeah so again I'm not going to get into
intelligence
um you know as we mentioned in our
statement last night once the balloon
was detected we acted immediately to
protect against the collection of
sensitive information and I'll just
leave it at that thank you Phil
is there any nuclear or radioactive
material aboard the balloon or is there
anything that's aboard the balloon that
that makes you believe that it could
pose a risk if it was shot down uh I I
short answer is no but again right now
we do not assess that that the the
balloon in its current configuration at
approximately sixty thousand feet poses
a physical or military threat to people
on the ground thank you Joe
um Ukraine question
um the small diameter bomb in the latest
Ukraine Aid package has the potential to
Target Crimea is that the intent behind
providing it now
uh so thanks for the question Joe so so
yes uh as part of the usai package we
will be providing uh ground launch small
diameter bombs to Ukraine uh this gives
them a longer range uh capability
long-range fires capability uh that will
enable them again to conduct operations
in defense of their country and to take
back their Sovereign territory and
Russian occupied areas when it comes to
Ukrainian plans on operations clearly
that is their decision there in the lead
for those so I'm not going to talk about
or speculate about potential future
operations but again all along we've
been working with them to provide them
with capabilities that will enable them
to be effective on the battlefield and
just as a follow-up to that can you talk
specifically about this particular group
of capabilities you know how are they
tailored to what's happening in Ukraine
now for instance there's equipment that
connects the various air defense systems
just can you speak to why the specific
package now
yeah sure so so again it's important to
look at this from uh from a Evolution
standpoint in terms of of adapting to
the conditions on the ground and so
we've been focused on several key areas
in the last few months to support
Ukraine specifically air defense
capabilities armor capabilities long
range fires capabilities and then
combined with training in order to
enable them to have the the ability to
conduct combined arms and so looking at
things like further enhancing and
enabling their integrated air defense
which I think everyone
continues to watch with horror as Russia
conducts aerial bombardment on civilian
targets throughout Ukraine so working
with them in those areas but also
through those combine through the
combined arms training enabling them to
be able to change the equation on the
front lines not only defend their
territory but take back Sovereign
territory thank you
on that one within the in the
announcement there's a one line that
says Precision guided Rockets is that
the ground launch that is the ground
launch small diameter bomb thank you
yep okay Tara
uh just going back to the Ukraine
package can you talk a little bit more
about integrating the air defense
systems particularly all the systems
that have been sent by different NATO
partners and how do you integrate those
with the systems Ukraine already has
yeah so um without going into
operationally sensitive matters broadly
speaking uh so so a couple of things so
first of all it's important to recognize
that the ukrainians already have done a
fairly remarkable job of protecting uh
you know of employing the air defense
capabilities that they have that said we
do recognize that as they they take
these new pieces and parts and integrate
it into their system uh support
continued support is required and so we
consult regularly with the ukrainians
and our International allies and
partners and how they can best integrate
those systems so that is ongoing work
um you know but again they've been doing
a pretty remarkable job of intercepting
Russian missiles and drones
thank you all right time for just a
couple more Oren
two questions on the balloon first on
maneuverability can it maneuver up and
down as well as laterally in other words
turn as well as change altitude and and
in terms of tracking how are you
tracking this is it radar is it aircraft
and is it continuous tracking or is it
more intermittent than that yeah thanks
Lauren so uh Beyond saying that we are
continuously tracking uh the balloon I'm
not going to go into the specifics in
terms of how uh we track other than to
say that we have multiple means at our
disposal to do that in terms of more
specifics on the balloon again I'm not
going to get into intelligence again
other than it is maneuverable and I'll
just leave it at that all right two two
more questions Phil and then costume the
Chinese you said it changed course did
it change course following your
disclosure of uh its presence over the
United States and secondly is the you
know to to the to the point about its
capabilities
um you know how does how is it powered
how is it moving
um how does it how is it maneuverable
yeah thanks Phil so again uh on your
latter question I'm not I'm not going to
get into intelligence uh clearly it's a
balloon that has a payload underneath it
uh you know they'll just leave it at
that
um
what's that
uh it's got a large payload underneath
the surveillance component underneath
the actual balloon piece of it
um so just leave it at that and then in
terms of the um
the the maneuverability uh again all I
can say right now is at this point again
it's moving Eastward across the United
States currently over about the central
United States
looking for this
I I don't have that information
payload that sounds like Munitions or
something that would pose a threat to no
again there is a it is a surveillance
balloon right so there is a there is a
uh
surveillance capability underneath this
large balloon right so
you look at a blimp a blimp has a basket
right so there's a basket underneath it
in layman's terms so again large enough
to be concerning uh if there were a
debris field so all right custom last
question has there been any Mill to Mill
communication with China with respect to
the balloon again we've we've
communicated at multiple levels and I'll
just leave it at that okay yeah
is it aren't when is it munitions it is
a surveillance balloon again does not
pose we currently assess it does not
pose a physical or military risk to
people on the ground
payload that is it an engine I'm just
I'm trying I can't go into more details
so okay thank you very much everybody
appreciate it